eine heftige explosion auf einem
riesigen containerschiffe die container
gingen hoch wie raketen eine gewaltige
explosion
ich konnte nichts sehen überall
schwarzer rauch eine flammenhölle alle
mann von bord
wenn einmal etwas explodiert kann das
noch mal passieren das kann sehr schnell
eskalieren alles ist komplett verwüstet
schließlich kommen die ermittler an bord
alle container waren zerstört totales
chaos
wie sollen wir da etwas finden
sie entdecken spuren eines chemischen
cocktails der aus dem schiff eine
tickende zeitbombe gemacht hat
das war klar wenn es zu einer chemischen
reaktion kommt explodiert das eine
gefahr die vielen schiffen droht
weltweit ein toll wenn sich nichts
ändert werden weiter schiffe zerstört
und menschen getötet
abendstimmung im hafen von new orleans
die sonne ist untergegangen und es ist
immer noch heiss das 300 meter lange
container schiff flaminia wird beladen
es war ein schöner abend sony flaminio
wurde mit allem möglichen beladen
vermutlich 1000 verschiedene sachen
alles in ordnung da unten
der erste offizier stars utah überwacht
den beladen vorgang wie viele container
im laderaum 4 262
ich verteilte die aufgaben an die crew
zwölf stunden dauert das beladen danach
nimmt die flamini akku so viel nächstes
ziel und entladen das ist eine große
aufgabe
wir müssen alle container checken und
dafür sorgen dass sie an der richtigen
stelle landen nachdem her sind wir voll
von matrosen bremer ruck ist erst seit
drei monaten auf dem schiff
die arbeit ist hart aber man findet
viele gute freunde
wir sind wie brüder das schiff ist unser
zweites zuhause
vollgeladen transportiert die flamini
mehr als 3000 container jeder einzelne
wird je nach gewicht ladung und
bestimmungsort positioniert wir haben
einen lageplan neuer 123 etwa so
gefahrgut container kommen entweder in
den laderaum oder in bestimmte bereiche
an deck
gefährliche ätzende oder entflammbarer
güter bekommen ein spezielles etikett
die acht riesigen frachträume sind mit
vertikalen schienen ausgestattet sie
bringen jeden container auf seine
position das system ist auf maximale
geschwindigkeit ausgelegt das läuft
schnell und präzise containerkräne sind
heutzutage enorm effizient was früher
wochen dauerte dauert heute stunden
ist der laderaum voll wird er mit
riesigen deckeln verschlossen
darauf werden weitere container
gestapelt
jeden tag sind weltweit mindestens fünf
millionen container unterwegs das ist
wie eine mischung aus ballett und
fließband es ist wunderschön der bogen
aus containern hoch oben in der luft die
laster die einer nach dem anderen b oder
entladen werden
in den containern sind kleidung möbel
und andere konsumgüter aber auch
industriechemikalien für den
europäischen markt
90 prozent aller waren werden in
containern transportiert
bereits im deck sichern bereits
sobald alles verladen ist zu sichern die
hafenarbeiter die letzten container für
die reise
am nächsten morgen stich die flaminia in
seenot eingeschaltet
für die 10.000 kilometer lange reise
nach antworten braucht das schiff circa
15 tagen
neben 23 offizieren und
besatzungsmitgliedern fahren auch
zahlende passagiere mit in ein flugzeug
zu steigen ist natürlich einfacher aber
auch langweilig
containerschiffe machen viel mehr spaß
du bezahlst und sie nehme dich mit
johnny rosen hat ein ticket gebucht
nicht die schnellste art den atlantik zu
überqueren aber für ihn die beste
wenn du frei und ungebunden bist ist es
die egal wann du ankommst so ein
frachter ist perfekt
das beste ist kommen sie rein du kannst
dich auf dem schiff frei bewegen auf der
brücke mit der crew abhängen und sie mit
fragen löchern
das ist das ganze schiff
sie sind stolz auf ihr schiff und wollen
dir alles zeigen vom maschinenraum bis
rauf nach oben einfach alles es ist ihr
baby und das führen sie gerne vor
darf ich ja sicher
gerne süßes utah ist stellvertreter des
kapitäns der erstaunliches jutta
wahnsinns nach der ankunft will der
erste offizier nach hause zu seiner
familie
er hatte eine frau und ein kind in polen
und freute sich zu ihm zurückzukehren
auch andere besatzungsmitglieder freuen
sich auf ihren heimaturlaub einer davon
ist matrose rama.com er kann es kaum
erwarten seine familie wieder zu sehen
sein nur selten er war sieben bis neun
monate am stück unterwegs dann für zwei
monate zu hause
er freute sich jedes mal wahnsinnig auf
uns er schrieb mir wie geht es dir
nächste woche bin ich wieder da dann
sehen wir uns ich liebe dich ich schrieb
ihm ich liebe dich auch bis dann
nach 13 tagen hat die flaminia einen
großen teil der strecke zurückgelegt die
reise über den atlantik verläuft ohne
probleme
bisher
brauchen frachtraum 4
die sensoren melden ein problem in einem
der laderäume
gab der kapitän alarm im frachtraum 4
in dem riesigen frachtraum stehen 262
container unmöglich zu sagen welcher
davon den alarm ausgelöst hat
das schiff ist randvoll beladen 14
container reihen nebeneinander jeweils
neuen container hoch 160 container
stehen oben auf den lippen wenn irgendwo
unten ein feuer ausbricht hat man ein
problem
ich übernehme der kapitän übernimmt das
kommando team zusammenstellen
zum sammelplatz
ich hörte das signal
feueralarm
ibrahim gehört im ernstfall zur bord
feuerwehr
was ist los ich weiß nicht ich hatte
angst das war echt mein erstes richtiges
feuer
maschinen stopp der kapitän leitete ein
sicherheits manöver ein das schiff fuhr
mit 20 knoten bei einem feuer soll der
wind nicht mit 20 seemeilen pro stunde
über steck blasen also stoppt man das
schiff
brenders weiß nicht auf
dem sammelplatz helfen wir uns
gegenseitig in die schutzanzüge
alle seeleute waren in aktion jeder
hatte einen schlauch auf der schulter
alle möglichen geräte und feuerlöscher
wurden nach vorne geschleppt
kommt so schnell wie möglich zum
frachtraum 4
die anderen folgt mir
auf containerschiffen gibt es zwei
methoden der brandbekämpfung entweder
löschen mit schläuchen oder ersticken
mit co2 co2 freisetzen und laderaum 4
ein feuer braucht drei dinge brennstoff
hitze und sauerstoff
co2 laderaum 4 um es zu löschen musst du
einen dieser faktoren ausschalten und
das schiff hat ein eingebautes
brandbekämpfung system
kohlenstoffdioxid wird in die laderäume
geleitet um das feuer zu ersticken
wenn co2 in einem geschlossenen raum
strömt wird der gesamte sauerstoff
verdrängt und das feuer erlischt so ist
es jedenfalls gedacht
aber dieses mal
geht etwas schief
das ist ein maschinenraum das co2 ist in
den maschinenraum gelangt da hat es
nichts zu suchen einige systeme schalten
automatisch ab die maschine lässt sich
nicht wieder starten wenn die maschine
nicht läuft ist das in vielen
situationen ein problem mit zb während
eines feuers der wind dreht kann der
kapitän praktisch nicht darauf reagieren
die firma war zu weit draußen für die
hubschrauber sie waren auf sich allein
gestellt
die löschkräfte was auch immer da unten
quandt es wird schlimmer
weiß nicht er war nicht bloß rauch da
war richtig viel rauch das co2 scheint
nichts zu bewirken schleich einschließen
es ist schwierig im laderaum mit
schläuchen zu arbeiten deshalb versucht
man das feuer einzudämmen indem man den
bereich rundherum nass macht wenn das
klappt ist viel gewonnen
die männer arbeiten unter hochdruck
ich bin gerade mit dem schlauch zugange
und dann
die container flogen vom deck wie
raketen das ganze schiff bebte
ein gewaltiger feuerball schießt aus dem
frachtraum der kapitän weiß nicht ob die
lösch pro das überlebt hat
ich war am sammelpunkt und in sicherheit
einer schrie sie sind alle tot alle tot
das containerschiff la mia steht in
flammen mitten auf dem atlantik
sieben männer der board feuerwehr werden
vermisst
das schiff brannte überall vatikan auch
die explosion hatte die luken deckel
weggesprengt container wurden ins meer
geschleudert das feuer war außer
kontrolle
tausende container sind doch an bord
bevor noch mehr in die luft gehen musste
kapitän die crew von bord schaffen
sie mussten mit weiteren explosionen
rechnen das schiff war eine tickende
zeitbombe
es könnte jeden moment noch schlimmer
werden die männer klettern in ein
rettungsboot am hinteren teil des
schiffes der kapitän versucht diese spur
zu erreichen
er weiß nicht ob jemand überlebt hat
niemand antwortete auf den funkspruch
des kapitäns
die explosion auf dem verdeck überlebt
aber er kann kaum etwas hören
ich weiß nicht was mit mir los war da
war bloß dieses pfeifen wie ein echo auf
beiden seiten
ich blutete und konnte schlecht sehen
überall war schwarzer rauch und dann
hörte ich etwas
[Musik]
ich koche zu ihm hin
ich sagte bleibt liegen wenn du
aufstehst sterben wir
oben war feuer
wir kochen nach vorne
die überlebenden waren am vorderen ende
von fracht luke 4 nur ein paar meter
weiter wütete das feuer der weg nach
hinten war durch heruntergefallene
container blockiert sie waren auf sich
allein gestellt am bug des brennenden
schiffes im kwan findet des perrons vier
weitere crewmitglieder
zwei männer werden noch vermisst wo ist
der rest matrose ramon park on und der
erste offizier
die sicherheit der besatzung dafür bin
ich verantwortlich
ich ging wieder zurück sie zu suchen ich
rief erster offizier ramon
und der erste offizier waren zusammen
gewesen
ich sah einen aus der crew
aber wer war das ich konnte ihn nicht
identifizieren
er war total verbrannt
holt die planer der erste offizier erst
com bei bewusstsein
es war schlimm
sein körper war verbrannt dabei er
konnte noch sprechen
trotz bahn
einer stimme ich höre sie noch immer
danke danke putz du hast mich gefunden
wir holen dich hier raus
die crew am anderen ende des schiffes
ist inzwischen im rettungsboot fordere
station bitte kommen der kapitän setzt
einen letzten verzweifelten funkspruch
ab und fordere station bitte kommen chef
der kapitän
der kapitän schrie vordere station
fordere station ich konnte nichts hören
kapitän hier bootsmann wird verletzt sie
leben es gab also verletzte die würden
sie nicht im stich lassen las die leiter
runter gekommen euch verstanden los
geht's sie lassen die note leiter runter
bereit für die rettungsaktion der
kapitän musste so schnell wie möglich
sein keiner wusste waren die nächste
explosion kommt
alleine lösen sie lassen das
rettungsboot router
ich schaute nach unten und sah die
container im wasser treiben
die treibenden trümmerteile und
container sind eine gefahr für das
rettungsboot es könnte leck schlagen
vorsichtig steuerte kapitän zum vorderen
teil des schiffes
es versucht weiter nach dem letzten
vermissten matrosen romonta com
ich schrie aber keine antwort
das rettungsboot schafft es durch das
trümmerfeld schon ist es an der flucht
leiter fordere station bereit machen die
verletzten männer helfen sich
gegenseitig jeden moment kann die
nächste explosion folgen bootsmann
kapitän an co2
wir müssen los
der kapitän sagte butt man runter vom
schiff wir müssen los
ich hatte keine wahl
ich ging von bord
ich weiß nicht was mit akon passiert ist
ich war sehr traurig ich kann nicht
glauben dass er tot ist
[Musik]
und den kapitän keiner sagte was
noch gestern waren wir glücklich gewesen
und hatten zusammen gesungen und jetzt
das
ich war geschockt sie hatten
verbrennungen eine wimpern keine
augenbrauen keine haare
theo tarver ganz still wir wussten dass
es schlecht um ihn statt
ich hatte angst dass die hälfte der
besatzung an ihren verletzungen stirbt
wenn uns in den nächsten 24 stunden
niemand rettet
[Musik]
wir warteten ein paar stunden im
rettungsboot
plötzlich tauchte am horizont ein schiff
auf die die ds crown sie kamen um uns zu
retten
das schiff hat den notruf empfangen die
überlebenden werden an bord geholt
als ich auf der ds crown bar und die
brennende flaminia sah wurde mir klar
was ich für ein glück gehabt hatte
wir haben überlebt jetzt sind wir auf
einem großen tanker dieses video
aufgenommen von einem besatzungsmitglied
zeigt wie knapp es war mein letzter
blick auf die msi flammen ja
es muss absolut furchtbar sein dein
schiff dein zuhause in flammen aufgehen
zu sehen das will kein seemann ihr leben
verzweifelt versuchen die männer den
ersten offizier zu retten aber es ist zu
spät cäsars utah erliegt seinen
verletzungen
ein zweites besatzungsmitglied stirbt
später im krankenhaus
da man talk on wird nie gefunden der
vierfache vater gilt als verschollen
aufsehen
eine woche nach seiner e mail sollte er
nach hause kommen
das machen wir jetzt war das erste was
mir in den sinn kam was machen wir denn
jetzt
zwei tage später treibt die flammen ja
immer noch brennen dem atlantik die
suche nach antworten hat derweil
begonnen
das schiff gehört einer deutschen
reederei deshalb übernimmt die
bundesstelle für seeunfalluntersuchung
den
fachleuten der ermittler ist harald
erdbeeren okay mal sehen
der fall musste unbedingt untersucht
werden schließlich hatte es eine
explosion und ein feuer an bord gegeben
menschen waren gestorben er ist kapitän
und experte für sicherheit in der
seefahrt er soll herausfinden was
geschehen ist und warum
konkrete beweise sind entscheidend
deshalb wollten wir unbedingt zum schiff
wenn es irgendwo beweise gibt dann an
bord der flaminia aber die treibt
brennend im atlantik etwa 1000 kilometer
vom nächsten land entfernt
bergungs meister christus soll sie vor
dem untergang bewahren
wir wollten das schiff und so viel wie
möglich von der ladung retten
boos leitet die operation als er
eintrifft brennt das feuer lichterloh
das team muss es löschen bevor das
schiff unwiederbringlich verloren ist
schwarzer rauch stieg auf wir gingen
näher ran um den brandherd zu
lokalisieren
dann begannen wir mit löschen tagelang
bekämpfen sie das feuer mit hochdruck
schläuchen an bord können sie erst wenn
die explosionsgefahr gebannt ist die
hast du immer im hinterkopf du behältst
chef ständig im auge bist die ganze zeit
in alarmbereitschaft
fast 3000 container sind doch an bord es
ist schwierig für bus und sein team zu
erkennen welche die gefährlichen sind du
weißt nicht welche giftig oder explosiv
sind du weißt nicht was als nächstes
passiert es gibt noch ein risiko die
löscharbeiten selbst
es kann passieren dass man das schiff
versenkt dass man retten will indem man
es die stabilisiert durch das ganze
wasser das man auf das feuer punkt
es ist immer schwierig immer
herausfordernd und kompliziert es ist
ein langer prozess bis wir sagen können
dass das feuer unter kontrolle ist
es dauert fast zwei monate bis das team
das feuer gelöscht hat und schlepper die
flaminia in einen hafen ziehen können
unterdessen trifft sich harald erdbeer
mit dem kapitän des schiffs und
mitgliedern der crew
wir erhoffen uns mehr informationen über
den hergang des unglücks und die ursache
der explosion
aber weder die crew noch der kapitän
können diese fragen beantworten
was glauben sie hat das feuer ausgelöst
da war überall rauch was der kapitän
weiß wirft noch mehr fragen auf wir
haben co2 freigesetzt offenbar ohne
wirkung er besteht vor einem doppelten
rätsel was hat die explosion verursacht
und warum versagte das löschsystem wir
müssen aufs schiff
fast zwei monate nach der explosion auf
der flaminia wird das immer noch
schwelende containerschiff nach
wilhelmshaven gebracht
als das schiff in den hafen kam lag der
gestank von verbranntem materialien und
containern in der luft
endlich kann harald erdbeer selbst an
bord wie sieht es da oben aus
alles ist komplett verwüstet unser corp
hing an einem der container kräne von da
haben wir bilder gemacht die
verwüstung im frachtraum bereich war
beträchtlich
fast alle container waren kaputt
das totale chaos
[Musik]
es war unmöglich zu sehen wo das feuer
oder die explosion begonnen hatte
die brücke ist noch weitgehend intakt
auch hier suchen die ermittler nach
spuren von
alle informationen werden im computer
aufgezeichnet die daten vom ruder von
der hauptmaschine sprachaufnahmen von
der brücke ein backup der daten befindet
sich auf dem sogenannten deutsch data
recorder kurz media können sie die
medial kapsel holen
sprachaufzeichnungen sind wichtig für
uns welche maßnahmen hat der kapitän
ergriffen die wurde das feuer bekämpft
wie hat er die lage eingeschätzt
der video das feuer nicht nur
überstanden erst in perfektem zustand
unser technischer offizier hat die media
daten aufbereitet
es werden zwar daten angezeigt aber die
geben wenig her es gab keine relevanten
daten
als die besatzung der schiffer lässt
laufen die systeme weiter komme knopf
das notfall backup wurde nicht gedrückt
alle zwei stunden werden die
videoaufzeichnungen automatische
beschrieben die daten vom zeitpunkt des
unfalls sind längst gelöscht
das war sehr ungünstig jetzt brauchten
wir einen neuen ansatz
keine video garten und kaum verwertbare
spuren im frachtraum erdbeer braucht
nicht nur einen neuen ansatz er braucht
eine chemikerin
willkommen im team danke ich bin kein
chemiker sie ist eine spezialistin wie
lange hat es gebrannt fast zwei monate
chemikerin dana meißner steuert ihr
fachwissen bei
feuer ist eine chemische reaktion
es ist schon sinnvoll die chemikerin zu
fragen was da eigentlich gebrannt hat
woher der sauerstoff kam und warum der
schaden so groß war
meißner leitete die abteilung forschung
und entwicklung am deutschen institut
für schiffssicherheit
mein erster gedanke war wie sollen wir
in diesem chaos bloß irgendwas finden
alles war komplett verwüstet
es waren 262 container im frachtraum 4
meißner muss zum inhalt jedes einzelnen
containers durchgehen die frage lautet
welcher von ihnen könnte eine explosion
ausgelöst haben die stark genug war um
hunderte tonnen stahl und ladungen in
die luft zu schleudern
wir haben die gesamte ladung untersucht
ich habe eine grafik erstellt die zeigt
was alles nah beieinander lag
der würze
kokosnüsse
[Musik]
katzenstreu baumwolle lauter total
verschiedene sachen direkt nebeneinander
mehr als hundert container enthalten
rohmaterialien für die industrie und
potenziell gefährliche chemikalien
im nächsten schritt haben wir überprüft
ob einzelne ladungen mit materialien in
der umgebung reagieren konnten
die lange liste enthält einen
hauptverdächtigen
pvc
nicht weniger als 90 container in und
auf frachtraum vier sind mit pvc pulver
geführt es findet vielerlei anwendungen
von der kreditkarte bis zum t-shirt
pvc ist gefährlich wenn es erhitzt wird
es kann mit stahl reagieren und hoch
explosiven wasserstoff erzeugen
wasserstoff kann weißlich grauen rauch
erzeugen ähnlich dem was die crew nach
dem alarm seien
so konnte das pvc genug wasserstoffgas
erzeugen um eine so gewaltige explosion
zu verursachen aber
meist nur glaubt zu wissen was da
explodiert ist aber die ursache muss
woanders liegen
pvc muss sehr heiß werden um wasserstoff
zu erzeugen
pvc erwärmt sich nicht von selbst etwas
anderes muss sehr heiß geworden sein und
es erhitzt haben
aber was
die techniker untersuchen die
rauchmeldeanlage der flaminia sie ist
noch intakt
diesmal rauchmelder ist eigentlich ein
schnüffler er saugt die luft aus den
laderäumen und analysiert ob partikel in
der luft sind dann schlägt er alarm
was auch immer den alarm ausgelöst hat
hat möglicherweise rückstände in den
schläuchen des systems hinterlassen das
könnte der entscheidende hinweis sein
die experten vermuten dass es im
frachtraum vier zu starker
hitzeentwicklung gekommen ist einige der
90 pvc container wurden offenbar so heiß
dass sie explodiert sind
spuren des verantwortlichen stoffes
könnten in den schläuchen des
rauchmelders zurückgeblieben seien die
frage war ob etwas aus dem frachtraum in
die schläuche gesaugt worden war
die technik entdecken spuren von die
vinyl benzol kurz dvb wenn ich
chemikalie die ihn industrieklebstoffen
verwendet wird
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich sind die dvb moleküle aus
dem container entwichen und in die
schläuche gelangt
mit dem neuen hinweis checkt meist nur
noch einmal ihre tabelle
in dem frachtraum waren drei container
mit dvb
t dvb ist sehr reaktiv und gefährlich
und es kann sehr heiß werden
drei container mit der reaktiven
chemikalie sind mitten im laderaum
verstaut rechts und links davon
container mit pvc weil dvb so gefährlich
ist wird es für den transport mit einem
chemischen stabilisator versetzt dieser
verhindert dass es reagiert und sich
erhitzt
unter normalen bedingungen hält die
wirkung des stabilisators etwa 60 tage
lang an
mehr als genug zeit für die überfahrt
person und trotzdem beginnt die
chemische reaktion schon 13 tage nachdem
die familie new orleans verlassen hat
das schiff explodiert hier
erdbeer wendet sich an den biochemiker
dr thomas höfer kann erklären warum das
dvb früher reagiert als erwartet
die wirkung der stabilisierung lässt mit
der zeit nach wir mussten nun
herausfinden wann die chemische reaktion
in gang kam
wenn wir die reise der container
zurückverfolgen hat sie hier begonnen in
baton rouge
und in baton rouge wurde das dvb in
tankcontainer gefüllt und nach new
orleans transportiert bei der
rekonstruktion des transports stoßen die
ermittler auf etwas unerwartetes
niemand hat die umgebungstemperatur
beachtet wir fanden heraus dass die
chemikalien im hafen einer temperatur
von mehr als 30 grad celsius ausgesetzt
waren
bei hohen temperaturen verliert ich mag
alle die das dvb stabilisieren soll ihre
wirkung schneller die container brüten
geschlagene zehn tage lang in der heißen
sonne
ich musste unbedingt herauskriegen wie
lange die container schon unterwegs
waren bevor sie an bord kamen
wie lange war da der stabilisator noch
haltbar
bei einer temperatur von 18 grad reicht
der stabilisator für 60 tage
anhand der realen außentemperatur konnte
ich berechnen wie lange der stabilisator
tatsächlich gewirkt hat
steigt die temperatur auf 27 grad
verkürzt sich die wirkungszeit auf 30
tage
je wärmer es wird desto schneller
versagt der stabilisator
richtig
ohne stabilisator reagiert das dvb und
dann wird s heiß
und die heiße sonne in louisiana könnte
die lebensdauer des stabilisators
halbiert haben aber selbst dann müsste
es für die atlantiküberquerung gereicht
haben gab es noch einen anderen faktor
wir schauten uns die temperatur rund um
die drei container an höfer muss nicht
lange suchen schon bald entdeckte
weitere probleme im frachtraum
sehen sie die container
die sind heiß
wir stellten fest dass die container von
beheizten containern umgeben waren
zehn behälter mit einer chemikalie die
für den transport geschmolzen wird man
erhitzt sie auf 80 90 grad die container
stehen nicht einfach irgendwo sondern
direkt neben dem dvd
also wird das dvb von allen seiten
erwärmt exakt das ist also der auslöser
für die explosion
diese schaltete den stabilisator aus und
das dvb setzt eine tödliche
kettenreaktion in gang
die temperatur stieg auf 200 bis 350
grad celsius
der druck endlich aus den containern das
war dieser heiße weiße rauch
die steigende temperatur verwandelt den
ganzen laderaum in einen riesigen
schnellkochtopf
möglicherweise wird es so heiß das sind
in 90 containern mit pvc explosiver
wasserstoff entsteht
der hitze war eine explosion
unvermeidlich
es ist das letzte puzzleteil vermutlich
ist es so zur explosion im frachtraum
gekommen aber die ermittler haben noch
eine weitere wichtige frage zu
beantworten
die besatzung hat co2 eingeleitet warum
hat das die explosion nicht verhindert
die co2 innenraum vier einleiten co2 im
laderaum 4
die ermittler wissen dass kapitän und
crew schnell reagiert haben als der
feueralarm ausgelöst wurde was ist bei
der löschaktion schief gelaufen wir
haben co2 freigesetzt offenbar ohne
wirkung
gutachter untersuchen das
brandbekämpfung system der flaminia
sie fanden heraus dass es im co2 system
einen falschen anschluss für die
laderäume gab
es zeigt sich dass die leitungen nicht
korrekt verbunden waren während das gas
im frachtraum vier strömte co2 wird
freigesetzt löst eine falsche verbindung
einen fehlalarm im maschinenraum aus
deswegen konnte die hauptmaschine nicht
wieder gestartet werden
die belüftung des maschinenraums wurde
automatisch abgeschaltet und damit auch
der kessel das verhinderte den neustart
der maschine wir verlieren die
hauptmaschine das größte problem daran
war dass die kuh in einer phase
abgelenkt war in der viele dinge
gleichzeitig passierten
obwohl die flammen ja seit mehr als zehn
jahren im einsatz war wusste niemand
etwas von dem fehler
es wurde schon in der werft beim einbau
das system ist falsch gemacht die
ermittler identifizieren andere schiffe
mit dem gleichen system was sich
herausfinden ist nicht beruhigend
wir glauben dass sieben schiffe aus
dieser serie den gleichen fehler hatten
die schiffe werden sofort zur reparatur
beordert
die installations- fehler war gravierend
erklärt aber nicht die katastrophe
gutachter bestätigen dass definitiv co2
in den frachtraum geleitet wurde
das ganze sollte den sauerstoff
verdrängen und die flammen ersticken
warum hat das nicht funktioniert
wenn es außerhalb der containerbrand ist
co2 sehr effektiv aber auf der flaminia
beginnt das problem innerhalb der
versiegelten container wenn es in einem
containerbrand bekommt man das co2 kaum
hinein
das kohlendioxid kommt nicht in die
container genauso wenig wie wasser kein
löschmittel kommt in die container weil
sie versiegelt sind das ist das problem
wenn es in einem container tief unten im
laderaum eines schiffes brennt kann man
das feuer praktisch nicht löschen
diese schlacht konnten die männer nicht
gewinnen
die crew hat alles richtig gemacht sie
konnte nur einsetzen was er zur
verfügung stand
die brandbekämpfung systeme an bord sind
offenbar keine lösung des problems im
jahr des la mia unglücks gab es im
schnitt jede woche ein feuer oder einer
explosion auf einem containerschiff
täglich sind weltweit mehr als 5000
containerschiffe unterwegs wie groß ist
die gefahr für die besatzungen
solange keine lösung gefunden wird wird
es tödliche containerbrände geben
während die gefährlichen container an
deck gewesen hätte die löschmannschaft
den brand vielleicht unter kontrolle
gebracht und die explosion verhindert
aber die container waren unter deck
diese chemikalie hätten niemals im
laderaum gelagert werden dürfen
wer hat das angeordnet und war das in
ordnung die ermittler wühlen sich durch
die originalunterlagen wie kann es sein
dass seine gefährliche chemikalie wie
dvb tief unten im laderaum verstaut
wurde
the chemical company die chemiefirma
muss die gefahren ausweisen und sagen
wie die ware gelagert werden muss ob an
oder unter deck also forderten wir die
entsprechenden unterlagen an die papiere
enthalten die anweisungen des
herstellers für den umgang mit dvb wenn
sie sich das an nicht über wärmequellen
staunen an deck lagern und temperatur
überwachen es durfte keiner hitze
ausgesetzt werden und musste an deck
gelagert werden damit die temperatur
überwacht werden konnte sinnvolle
anweisungen aber die crew kannte sie
nicht in den begleitpapieren wurde also
vor den gefahren gewarnt alles in
ordnung da unten grasser alles in
ordnung nur sind die papiere offenbaren
nicht an bord angekommen mussten deshalb
drei männer sterben
der hersteller des dvb hatte die
gefährliche chemikalien nicht im sommer
über new orleans verschiffen sollen und
der spediteur hätte sie nicht zehn tage
lang im hafen liegen lassen dürfen
die verlade firma an land ist für den
ladevorgang und die papiere
verantwortlich die besatzung weiß
meistens gar nicht was in den containern
ist
ein zivilgericht entscheidet das an bord
keine fehler gemacht wurden die
anweisungen des herstellers wurden im
lageplan nicht berücksichtigt es bleibt
unklar warum der kapitän und der erste
offizier keine informationen darüber
hatten dass diese container an deck
gehört hätten und
so wurde das dvb einfach entsprechend
der klassifizierung außen auf dem
container verlagen
gemäß internationaler vorschriften
werden gefährliche güter in kategorien
unterteilt wie explosiv entflammbar
giftig oder ätzend das dvb fielen zwei
verschiedene kategorien erster salz
gefährlicher stoff zweitens als
meeresverschmutzung diese einstufung
besiegelte das schicksal der männer an
bord der flaminia
wenn er es meeres verschmutzt ist darf
man es nicht an deck lagern dies deshalb
entschied der verlader völlig zu recht
es in die mitte des laderaums zu packen
die besatzung hatte keine ahnung dass im
frachtraum eine zeitbombe tickt eine
gefährliche chemische reaktion
auch im frachtraum 4
hat sie das problem bemerken
co2 freigesetzt war es schon zu spät
das schicksal nahm seinen lauf
die explosion war letztlich oft die
klassifizierung der chemikalie
zurückzuführen denn ihretwegen landete
sie im frachtraum
das war ein fehler das hätte man so
nicht klassifizieren dürfen das problem
betrifft containerschiffe auf der ganzen
welt
ein einziger falscher ausgezeichneter
container mit feuer gefährlicher ladung
genügt um ein großes schiff zu zerstören
das risiko wächst bei container schiffe
immer größer werden zu ihrer zeit war
die flaminia eines der größten
containerschiffe der welt verglichen mit
heutigen schiffen war sie eher klein um
die weltweite nachfrage zu bedienen
transportieren heutige schiffe bis zu
dreimal so viele container die damals
die flaminia
große lösungen schaffen oft große
probleme je größer das schiff desto
höher die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein
container probleme macht den preis
zahlen die seeleute die ums leben kommen
und die reeder die ihre schiffe
verlieren dagegen müssen wir etwas tun
der fall kommt vor die internationale
seeschifffahrtsorganisation
sie soll die klassifizierung von dvb
ändern
nach dem unfall der flammen ja wurde dvb
in eine andere gefahren klasse
eingestuft
die container rankommen können und
regelmäßig die temperatur messen weil es
gefährlich ist
die phobie ist jetzt in derselben
kategorie wie einige arten von tnt
eine vorschrift die leben retten kann
aber täglich werden millionen container
über die weltmeere transportiert es gibt
noch viel zu tun
die containerschifffahrt ist fluch und
segen zugleich weltweit gibt es viele
gefahrengüter und es ist kaum zu
garantieren dass jeder container
ordnungsgemäß gekennzeichnet und
gehandhabt wird
die gute nachricht ist dass sich der
fehler von new orleans nicht wiederholen
wird die schlechte ist dass es viele
andere chemikalien gibt und viele andere
potenzielle fehler
bei der explosion auf der flamini
ackermann drei besatzungsmitglieder ums
leben darunter der erste offizier
der erste offizier hat die aufgabe die
crew zu beschützen das hat er hat
großartige arbeit geleistet aber das
kostete ihn das leben arnold des perrons
hat nie wieder auf einem schiff
gearbeitet der verlust seiner
mannschaftskameraden macht ihm immer
noch zu schaffen
an jedem jahrestag denke ich an unser
unglück
das leben ist kurz
es ist wie ein zauber und dann ist das
vorbei
bonn
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass meine kameraden in
frieden ruhen ramon parcom wurde nie
gefunden
meine mutter und ich sind nach
deutschland geflogen wir wollten die
flammen ja mit eigenen augen sehen
[Musik]
seine familie erwies ihm die letzte ehre
wenn wir weinten als wir das schiff sei
der container container waren
geschmolzen alles verbrannt
das hat mein vater erlebt
ich hatte gehofft dass er mit uns alt
werden würde wer mehr zeit miteinander
verbringen könnten
aber es sollte nicht sein
[Musik]